[Music]
so you know truth goes hand-in-hand with
fact you know true a truth is a true
proposition which is a kind of claim
about and you can use very mundane
example snow is white you know of course
even the most mundane examples Harbor
lots of complexities because white is a
color and question about the properties
colors are and so on and so forth but
but basically a truth is a true
proposition and on what we think is when
there is a truth proposition then there
is a fact that corresponds to that true
proposition it doesn't have to be a very
heavy-duty notion of correspond so what
people some people believe is that no
fact simply sits out there irrespective
of human beings or human minds or human
intervention or something like that that
fact which is basically when an object
has a certain property it's always in
some way constructed by human activity
mental activity in particular I guess
they think you know it has to be
categorized as that by a human mind
otherwise it wouldn't be a fact now
there really the thing about this that
should strike one
off the bat is peculiar is that we tend
to think that human beings came onto the
scene quite late so there were things
that existed before human beings existed
and that sets up a puzzle about how
human beings could have constructed all
the facts when some of the facts
presumably antedated the arrival of
human beings so of course you know there
are answers that the constructivist can
give to that but and they are not very
they're neither very satisfactory nor
very intuitive because we have to say
well we can construct our own past okay
but given that we're now already very
close to saying things that are hard to
understand
the real question is what's the
motivation why do people want to say
something as counterintuitive as that
all facts are constructed by human
mental activity so there you enter into
a kind of quest for diagnosis you know
what what drove people to say this and
there are many different streams that
contribute to this but one of them that
you see a lot in contemporary thinking
which really drives me crazy is that
it's a conflation of the notion of what
is widely accepted to be a fact with
what is a fact and the reason people
make this conflation is that they think
well you know if somebody says that
something is a fact
nobody has they think access to the
facts I mean if people are disputing
whether something is a fact there is the
fact that as it were one person believes
it's a fact and the other person doesn't
believe it and then one person the
person believes that it's a fact might
be supported by a whole bunch of other
people all of whom also believed that
it's a fact and so that becomes a widely
accepted fact and when those kinds of
situations they can bully the person who
doesn't believe it's a fact or they can
outnumber them or they can outlive them
or they can whatever if they will
somehow prevail and so what really
matters is whether something is widely
accepted to be a fact how could it
matter whether it is or is not a fact
and so through that process and maybe a
few other steps you begin to eliminate
the notion of
some things being a fact and you replace
it with the notion of something's being
accepted to be a fact now this notion of
being accepted widely accepted or taken
for granted to be a fact is a socially
constructed notion you see that is prez
it's a fact about societies whether or
not they are they accept something to be
a fact yes so you know of course
something that's widely accepted to be a
fact is that the Earth revolves around
the Sun and not the other way around
which is what people used to think like
vehicle not flat which is what a long
time ago before the Greeks people used
to think understand that an agreed
agreement about a widely accepted to be
a fact rather than the fact in itself
well so what I'm saying is that in what
people sometimes get themselves into a
frame of mind of thinking is we don't
need the notion of a fact what we need
is just the notion of a widely accepted
to be effect because that's really what
matters they're mistaken in this but but
that's I think part of the motivation
they just think whether something is or
is not a fact drops out as irrelevant
what really matters socially what really
matters in the argument is whether
something is widely accepted to the
effect and you can see this in the way
in which even journalists talk like this
you know and so they will say things
like is evolution a fact or just an
opinion or just a theory that that's the
contrast is it a factor is it just a
theory where they mean is this something
that people are toying around with or is
it widely accepted but that's a terrible
match that is it is a
misguided way of thinking about things
because what with your aiming and when
you aim to discover whether to accept
something as a fact and then whether to
make it to be a widely accepted fact is
whether it's is a fact so you know what
people were trying to figure out is what
is the shape of the earth yes they used
to believe it's flat let's say and then
people thought well there's some very
interesting astronomical data that can't
be accounted for if you think that it's
just some disk right after all for
instance you know things seem to dip
over the horizon as you as you walk
towards them one direction or another
and so you know actually the evidence
seems to suggest that it's spherical
which is surprising and a magnificent
achievement of human reason to have
figured that out on the basis of very
spare information but what they were
trying to do is figure out what the
facts are they weren't trying to figure
out what the widely accepted facts are
we know what the widely accepted facts
are in fact one of the things that went
on in that case is that you replaced one
widely accepted fact with another
because you discovered that what was
widely accepted to be effect wasn't a
fact you cannot make sense of that
distinction if you collapse the
distinction between fact and widely
accepted to be a fact I guess
a lot of the thinkers who argued that
there isn't actually you know kind of an
objective reality out there would bring
as examples the way in which the
different species see reality and to
some extent they would argue that
actually you know we humans might see
the colors that we see in one way and
that's like a widely accepted fact for
us but actually that's not an objective
it's not a reflection of objective
reality although what's your view on
that well so you know so my view about
colors is that in fact they're not real
this is a unusual view it was actually
the view of the 17th century so you know
when what happened was that people when
they discovered how to do physics in a
very effective way what they thought
well physics you know the physical
properties that we can work with are
basically mass extension you know
geometrical and other physical
properties but colors smells sounds all
of that is really just in the mind it's
the way the mind responds to physical
properties it's not really out there not
really out there that was Galileo's view
and the view of the British empiricists
and I think there is something to that
it's really a slightly specialist kind
of dispute because you can actually
reconcile my view with the view of
people think that colors are real
because what they really think is that
colors are real in the sense that they
are dispositions to cause certain kinds
of sensation in us so they don't really
mean the thing that would
be a direct clash with what with what I
believe so never never mind all of that
there is no doubt first two things one
of them is that in with regard to
certain properties they can look like
they in here in nature when they're
really just reactions within the mind
itself absolutely no problem the second
is that there is no doubt that there
could be other sentient beings such as
animals such as aliens with a different
physio chemistry and a different way of
interacting with the world different
sensorium who would see things
differently
none of this poses a problem for
objectivity why because as long as they
are consistent with one another they can
all be true together this is one of the
things that people sometimes don't
understand about the issue of relativism
relativism only becomes an issue when
you have two descriptions of the world
that are incompatible with one another
but both of which are said to be valid
or true
that's relativism now if I you know if I
have a certain sense or iam and I give
you a description of the world that's
correct
and then somebody else sees it and I
don't know a different part of the
spectrum and gives you a different
description but nevertheless consistent
with mine that's not an issue for us not
an issue for objectivity and what about
the comp like the conflicting narratives
so for instance I guess dreams or
sensations people have when they have
psychedelic drugs or something like that
because that obviously gives P
individuals very different experiences
from other human beings how did they fit
into an objective understanding of
reality well I mean I mean I take it
you'd have to say a bit more you can
have psychedelic experiences that of
course distort reality I'm any face if
they make this metal rod looked like
it's kind of fluctuating and you know
that that could be an interesting
experience and my teacher a few things
but it wouldn't be accurate wouldn't be
correct then of course there might be
things that it reveals that are
completely consistent with things that
you already know and they're just being
revealed to you by that experience
that's also great good so but as I say
the the issue of is there a single
reality to which all of our thought is
responsive
he's only joined if you think that there
are two descriptions of reality
incompatible with one another that are
both true okay so in these cases we have
an understanding of dreaming for
instance or of what a drug does to our
brain and we can have like an
Objectivist understanding of the world
and fit these different experiences
within that framework is that what
you're saying what did we do don't we
yeah and then in terms of you don't take
the agreement to be true if you're being
chased by a tiger in your dreams well it
can feel very real to you
but presumably it's not real so what you
can't do is say I'm both lying in bed
and I was being chased by a tiger now
you people can describe themselves in
that way as long as everybody
understands what's being said which is I
was lying in my bed I was asleep and I
dreamt I was being chased by a tiger it
felt very real to be so real that I
couldn't believe I was just dreaming and
when I woke up I was in a terrible sweat
yeah exactly so it is this feeling of
reality of reality right that is so
disturbing that it makes you doubt yes
there is a there is a feeling of reality
there is that absolutely and you can
sometimes have it when it's not real as
in dreams or psychedelic experiences now
the relevance of that is not so much to
the question of truth and relativism but
it is to the question of knowledge how
we know what is true how we know what is
a fact because if you can have this
feeling of reality when in fact it's
misleading you can get them to the
standard classical skeptical problem all
how do I know that that's not happening
right now I have the strong feeling of
reality things seem very consistent I
came to be sitting here talking to you
but maybe that's not real right so the
classical skepticism is north - it's a
real problem it's not dismissible it
doesn't raise any question about
relativism it doesn't raise any question
about truth
in fact presupposes that there is truth
and it's objective and the question is
how we know what it is you get much
worse skeptical the more of an
Objectivist you are about truth the more
skepticism you will have to deal with
so how skeptical are you well I'm not
very skeptical in the sense that you
know as Hume said it's it's very hard
actually to be a radical skeptic I mean
an ordinary life and you know it it also
is true although it would be hard to
explain all of this properly that you
know we aren't really aware of dreams
with the level of
coherence and consistency and detail
over time that that so-called ordinary
waking experience seems to have and we
certainly believe that we can tell that
distinction though I don't dismiss the
problem I think it's a problem for
philosophers to solve it's not but it's
not something that it's supposed as a
practical difficulty day by day um and
and the interview I was just wondering
if I could ask you one or two more
general questions one is what is an idea
you've changed your mind about recently
that's a good one because it there is in
fact you know if you look at the
literature I said I've just finished a
book on the a priori and one of the
things that happens in that book would
consist of a series of debates with
Timothy Williamson was also in the
program here is that I from the start of
the book which was about 15 years ago -
final piece in it I changed my view my
view about the importance of the notion
of intuition which is a notion that the
classical notion that used especially in
connection with a priority issues like
mathematics logic philosophy and so on
and I used to be very skeptical of the
value of this notion and I have since
become much more interested in it and
think it's much more indispensable for
explaining our knowledge of the a priori
then I used to think in what way is
intuition important well it's that you
know in the intuition as I'm using it is
what you might call an intellectual
impression of truth so just like we have
sensory impressions of truth
kind of visual perception of these
flowers and the grass and the river and
so on that so that presents you with a
certain fact right set of facts
similarly you can have intuitions that
are intellectual in nature they don't
have the same kind of vivid sensory
phenomenology but nevertheless they are
presentations of truth so if I say to
you you know two plus two is equal to
four you know what what's your basis for
thinking that you know you could you
could you could count things but which
is a kind of fallible way of but but at
the end of it you end up with the
impression that this claim is is true
and that's your basis for believing it
so and this is true for very general
things so for instance I mean to give an
example you say suppose you consider two
circles of unequal radii and you think
well they can most intersect one another
at two points and you can run a little
thought experiment in which you
manipulate the circles and you see this
very very general proposition which
applies to all circles under all
circumstances it's true and that's a
kind of intellectual impression of truth
as well well I guess you know with maps
maybe you know it's a safer area because
it's more abstract but for instance with
ethical judgments right that can seem
quite dangerous and a path to kind of
justifying prejudice
you raise a very good question and just
like sensory impressions can mislead
intellectual impressions can mislead
that is just the human condition and so
you always you don't just go on one
little bit of evidence so there are just
intellectual impressions of the truth of
certain very particular moral scenarios
so you know people do this kind of
thought experiment all the time should
you you know the trolley experiments and
that kind of thing you have to also see
what the underlying principle might be
that would yield this verdict in this
case and whether that principle seems
correct and then you have to bring them
all into some kind of equilibrium with
one another and so the same process by
the way that applies to figuring out
what the physical world is like also
applies to figuring out what the moral
world is like so the intuition or the
intellectual impression yes be helpful
but it should be taken with a pinch of
salt and a lot of evidence it is the
evidence it's just it they are the they
are the date they're the data with which
you work and what you need to do is
construct a coherent overall view that
reconciles both the individual verdicts
that you have along with the general
principles that you're inclined to
believe and if you you know hopefully
when you do that right you won't get
odious verdicts
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV
you